ALL OF THE NOMINEES FOR THE
BEST ADAPTED SCREENPLAY ARE
PHENOMENAL.
CHLOE ZHAO, BORN IN CHINA AND
RAISED IN THE U.K.,
CAME TO REALIZE THAT
HER EXPERIENCE AS AN OUTSIDER TO
THE AMERICAN DREAM GAVE HER A
UNIQUE WINDOW INTO EXAMINING IT.
THAT NICHE PERSPECTIVE DREW HER
TO "NOMADLAND".
RAMIN BAHRANI, NOMINATED FOR
"THE WHITE TIGER,"
PAID HIS WAY TO MAKING HIS OWN FILMS
WORKING AS A TRUCK DRIVER,
A BARTENDER, AND A TELEMARKETER...
WHOOF, TELEMARKETING.
I MAY HAVE HUNG UP ON YOU A FEW TIMES.
KEMP POWERS, HIS OWN PLAY,
"ONE NIGHT IN MIAMI," HE ADAPTED IT.
NOW, THERE'S SOME FUN FACTS IN
THE TELEPROMPTER,
BUT I'M GONNA GO OFF SCRIPT HERE.
THIS WAS HIS FIRST SCREENPLAY.
BEFORE, KEMP WAS A PLAYWRIGHT,
HE WAS A JOURNALIST,
AND ONE OF HIS FAVORITE FILMS
IS "ANIMAL HOUSE," WHICH IS WHERE HE
HEARD SAM COOKE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
FLORIAN ZELLER, ADAPTING HIS
PLAY "THE FATHER,"
SAW THE MOVIE "RAIN MAN,"
AND WAS INSPIRED
TO CREATE A CHARACTER
THAT ALLOWS US TO UNDERSTAND
ALZHEIMER'S THROUGH THE EYES
OF THOSE LIVING IT.
HIS COLLABORATOR,
CHRISTOPHER HAMPTON
WAS RAISED IN CAIRO, EGYPT
AND HIS MOVIE LOVE STEMS
FROM HIS FATHER TAKING HIM
TO THE MOVIES
THREE TIMES A WEEK!
I BET TICKETS WEREN'T
$13 APIECE BACK THEN.
OKAY, HERE WE GO:
SACHA BARON COHEN, DAN MAZER,
DAN SWIMER, ERICA RIVINOJA,
JENA FRIEDMAN, ANTHONY HINES,
LEE KERN, PETER BAYNHAM,
AND NINA PEDRAD FOR
"BORAT SUBSEQUENT MOVIEFILM:
DELIVERY OF PRODIGIOUS BRIBE TO
AMERICAN REGIME FOR MAKE BENEFIT
ONCE GLORIOUS NATION OF KAZAKHSTAN."
[ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
CHRISTOPHER HAMPTON
AND FLORIAN ZELLER
"THE FATHER".
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S SUCH A GREAT JOY AND
SUCH A GREAT HONOR.
AND I SHARE THESE JOYS
AND THIS AWARD
WITH CHRISTOPHER HAMPTON.
WE HAVE WORKED TOGETHER FOR YEARS
AND I WANT TO THANK HIM
FOR BEING SUCH A GREAT WRITER
AND SUCH A WONDERFUL FRIEND
AND I HAVE TO THANK EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN "THE FATHER"
AND EVERYONE WHO HELPED
ME TO MAKE THAT FILM,
UH, THAT SCRIPT,
BECOMING A FILM.
MY PRODUCERS, OF COURSE.
SIMON FRIEND
WHO FIRST PRODUCED
THE PLAY IN LONDON.
THE GREAT DAVID PARFITT,
PHILIPPE CARCASSONNE,
JEAN-LOUIS LIVI,
CHRISTOPHE SPADONE
THE SONY CLASSICS FAMILY
MICHAEL, TOM, MELODY
ALL MY TEAM AT CAA:
BRYAN, SORRY,
SO MANY NAMES THAT
I HAVE TO MENTION.
FREDERICA, CHRIS, ANDREW,
LAURENT, OLIVIER, SUZANNE
THANK YOU FOR BEING
SO SUPPORTIVE.
AND THE CREW OF
"THE FATHER," OF COURSE
AND THE WONDERFUL CAST:
OLIVIA WILLIAMS, OLIVIA COLMAN
RUFUS SEWELL, MARK GATISS,
IMOGEN POOTS, AND OF COURSE,
ANTHONY HOPKINS.
I WROTE THIS SCRIPT FOR HIM.
TO ME, HE'S THE
GREATEST LIVING ACTOR.
AND JUST THE IDEA TO WORK
WITH HIM WAS LIKE A DREAM.
AND I KNEW THAT IT WAS NOT
AN EASY DREAM TO FULFILL
BECAUSE I'M FRENCH,
AS YOU CAN HEAR.
IT WAS MY FIRST FEATURE FILM,
AND, YOU KNOW,
HE'S ANTHONY HOPKINS.
BUT I THOUGHT, UNTIL
SOMEONE COMES
AND PROVES THAT IT WAS
NOT POSSIBLE, IT MEANS THAT
POTENTIALLY IT IS.
AND SOMETIMES WE ARE
THE ONE WHO CLOSE THE DOOR
OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE
AND WHAT IS NOT POSSIBLE
AND FOR "THE FATHER,"
I REALLY WANTED NOT TO
CLOSE THAT DOOR
AND TO FOLLOW MY INSPIRATION,
MY DESIRE, AND MY DREAM.
SO, THANK YOU, ANTHONY,
FOR HAVING SAID YES TO THAT SCRIPT.
AND THANK YOU FOR GIVING
EVERYTHING TO THAT FILM.
YOUR ENERGY, YOUR GRACE,
AND YOUR TALENT.
SHARING THAT JOURNEY WITH YOU
WAS THE MOST AMAZING
EXPERIENCE OF MY LIFE.
AND AT LAST, I WANT TO
THANK MY WIFE, MARINE,
FOR SUPPORTING ME
WITH LOVE AND PATIENCE.
UH, THANK YOU TO THE ACADEMY.
[ APPLAUSE ]